okay
hello everyone we are here for a design
review
of spatial statistics for
upcoming version of wolfram language all
right
is the first time i've looked at this
project i think
it's been going for several years right
yeah it's a meaty topic
i expect us to have more than one
meeting um there are two guide pages
there are two views there's sort of the
data view and that's the model view
okay kind of like in in statistics you
have distributions
which are models and then you have sort
of data
you know just points basically and
observations
right okay okay all right so let's take
a look here
spatial point patterns is that the one i
want to go to
yeah but is that
okay so we've gone to some lengths to
not call them point patterns we're going
to change the name probably for that
guide page too because we figured
that calling them even though that's
what they regularly called
in our language that would probably lead
to unbelievable confusion
okay so this is
so can i just um to just orient just a
slide
okay so the thing that we study in this
the sort of two
big chunks of spatial statistics
and and probability so one
which is this one where we study a point
pattern which is a collection of point
and that might be
galaxies it might be trees it might be
cells in a you know under a microscope
yep it might be crime location it might
be
disease locations i get it yep i
understand
okay the other branch just to mention it
even though we're not
covering that here uh you're studying
um random fields
and that's kind of like i understand so
like population density of the earth
or the you know density of uh
i don't know you know temperature or
carbon dioxide or whatever else on the
earth is that right
yes okay and that's because
and things like that too that's a
continuous things it's like random
processes
you know for each point in time there's
a value for here each point in space
there is a value
right but there's empirical data that's
the number one issue there
rather than models i mean there's
empirical data about
you know the distribution of temperature
on the earth or something
yeah so actually in each point in space
there is a distribution
and so but that if you if you think of
all that's a different thing that's a
that's a
that's a random process model that's
what
that's what random fields are okay and
the fields are random processes
before we even get to that we're to walk
before we run
right the you know the first thing we
got to do is temperature field of the
earth
you know make statements about that time
series of temperature field of the earth
make statements about that right then
we've got
we've got a model for you know let's say
epidemiological model that predicts with
probabilities
what's going to happen in different well
that's a bad example we don't
yet believe in the viral field
hypothesis
that says that kinds of models in that
space which we're not doing today
are things like stochastic partial
differential equations
yeah okay micrograms fields that's a
running because we're not even walking
right now
i mean yeah the walking is we've got to
be able to ingest
the you know gridded population data of
the earth and be able to say what's the
expected population of this particular
geographic region with this particular
set of cutoffs
given this overall random field a random
distribution right
so well we have the capability to do
that right now
so this is not what we're covering today
okay i'm just describing the two big
branches of spatial studies i understand
but i'm saying there's a there's a third
sub-branch there which is the one that i
think is important
and way more important than stochastic
differential equations which is
way off in the stratosphere the basic
thing there is
you were given you know taking the
example of the thing i just raised right
yep
you're given the gridded population of
the earth and you're told
estimate you know somebody just uh
you know redrew the boundaries of
country x
estimate how many people are actually in
country x with the redrawn boundaries
in this project we did we did some work
on that and
i'll package that up in a way that would
that's that doesn't
bring in this whole total picture
and that's usually called kriging you
know this thing when you want to
figure out what the best expected value
is which this is a prediction
this is also known as the predicted
value um
so that's the conditional expected value
okay but it's important that we cover
these simple cases right we will okay
so we'll be worrying about stochastic
differential equations yes
we'll do something small there like that
okay
all right okay post this project
all right so let's take a look i i'm a
little bit concerned about the level of
technicality of these things given
given what i know is you know the core
issues okay so let's start in on what we
look at here
okay so what do we start with spatial
point data
you can look at that and so that's a
container so when you collect
point data um it's it's
it's very important to assume we have
jose and people representing the geo
crowd here yes no but i can get them
right now
okay go ahead so it's important to know
what the observation region is
so the fact that there is no event there
is significant
i'm saying yep otherwise the statistics
is
you know sort of so so in other words
usually in a statistical distribution
the information on the rain you know on
that it's a distribution on zero one is
kind of implicit in just in the
documentation
but here we have to expose that yeah as
a computable thing
yes so that's a region or geo reader i
realize i understand okay
so okay so this is now a little bit like
a time series
um this is not quite you know because
it's like an earthquake there's no
interpolated value
so that's the others okay well it
depends what it is if it's an earthquake
there's no interpolated value
although if it's the strain you know if
it's observations taken
about the strain of the earth there will
be interpreter interpolated values
but that's not what we're doing that's
the outer
branch that's what i was that's why i
was describing that
hmm
okay okay i understand what this is okay
all right so the other thing that's
common here is that you have
annotations for these observations so if
they're trees
you know you know some other properties
like diameter at breast height
and species are two very common things
yeah okay fine
so they're usually called marks there
are other things to do
these these yeah okay go ahead go ahead
there are other things that you can know
and they're usually views talked about
this covariate or input
there are things like elevation
i understand so there's a big bucket of
potentially an association
of properties associated with every
point yes
right i understand okay
okay all right so now what do we do with
this so first thing
we might want to do is visualize it so
for instance
if i want to visualize it showing the
just the density of trees in a
particular region what would i do
so is that just geodesic you just want
to visualize the yes
then then there are various ways to to
do that like geohistogram geosmooth
histogram and so on
but what about if i just want the points
if i just want to know what were the geo
positions in here
the kind of the analog point point point
value plot is the universal plot
function for this
okay and it works for both geo and on
year geo
okay so then then what we're talking
about here okay so
so by geo the way we're tagging geo
is that the points in here have either
just sp you know just coordinates
in that are just you know lists of n
coordinates
or we have explicitly geo
uh positions as the point position
as the descriptions of the point
locations yes is that is that right
yes okay
hello there we're talking about spatial
statistics in case you can't tell from
the title
right um
okay selecting subsets of data and
annotations
okay so i mean i'm just trying to
understand here
um well okay let me just keep going with
all of these things
okay
so that's just a function applied to the
payload of every point is that correct
yeah but you might also want to select
the sub you might also
only want to select the point that is in
this part of your space
right so how do you do that you have
this criteria function
but but i understand but but but but one
thing
oh there they go there's the table below
there this
hash point and go down
go down hash point and hash key
why is that key lock sk because they
they're they're defined by oh i see that
should have been an italic key
yes okay
um
okay so this is what you're doing here
is you're assuming the payload is an
association
and you're adding a faux additional
element to the association
which is the actual coordinates of the
point is that correct
yeah i mean that's not part it's the
they're not in the association they're
just points no no i understand but what
you're doing is
syntactically it is as if that i guess
you're right
i guess you're right actually yes yes
okay
so so for example one thing you should
obviously do
in the ingestion of spatial point data
is to allow it to take a list of
associations
that contain point as an element of the
association
am i making sense yes probably we should
do that
yes right so then then it all becomes
consistent and what you're saying here
is
there is a point thing that is
effectively added
as known to the association if you have
your own point value
then i don't know exactly what happens
and what takes precedence scotia maybe
you can say something about that
is that gosh is it go is this scotia's
project or who's
okay okay so can somebody say something
about that please
could you could you okay please pay
attention this is your one meeting
that we've been in together in forever
so please pay attention
okay roger can you repeat the question
so stephen suggested that we should
accept
annotations with point as one of the
keys right
okay okay so then i'm asking
if you specify if you have a key that
has the name
point what takes precedence
if you've specified hash point
do you understand what i'm saying yes
i'm just thinking because you can
you know you give the set of points and
then it's the matter of of agreeing on
what we want to take the presidents for
so no i understand but i'm asking right
now have you thought this through
presumably you know right now you have
to separately input the data
and then anything any addition the data
points the locations and then
everything that is additional
information has to be separate from that
so you know like you give the points and
this is the location
i i understand and then so if you're
asking
in this selection function what you're
doing which i'm not necessarily a super
big fan of
is you're letting the selection
criterion basically sample either
payload
you know elements or the position
correct yes i understand the question
now so basically if you give the point
and there is an annotation which has the
point as a key
it would take the point as the location
the wait a minute the key in the
association or the original value of the
point
the the location okay all right fine i'm
not sure i'm totally keen on
using point as the key name
why isn't it location i mean or is it or
position
i mean like we're using geoposition as
i don't know position has other
connotations
but points i mean this goes this is both
geo and non
geo like no i realize that i really
microscope yeah
location or something okay
in any case that okay so but basically
the point here is
as we talk about points the point of
point talking about points
etc um in any case this is basically a
select
that's happening so on a time series
what's the analogous function
so you can do the time series window to
select based on the timestamps
and for the selection on the values
decision on the
on oncoming feature so that would be
just a select that should work on the
values
okay so hold on so in time series we
plan a time series select
that works on values is that correct i
think that it would be maybe possible to
just
extend the select to work on time series
with the assumption that it will take
into account the selecting based on
values
okay hold on hold on so in time series
we have the exact same issue that we
have here
right we have the payload values and we
have
the time location right and selection
could
depend on both times here is a
continuous curves
so we have to be very serious event
series
um if i can i can i just comment one
thing so
why point and not location because we
are selecting based on the data points
and not the location which can be any
point within observation region
this is how we distinguish because some
of the statistics are based on
you know on for example distances
between the points
or between any location in observation
region to a data point
and therefore that's point to
distinguish between the location
which can be arbitrary placement in the
observation region
but point is the element which exists in
the data set
i think i understood that but i'm not
sure i understood that
you're saying location is something
where for example if i'm trying to
sample
what is the inferred value
at this particular position you're
thinking of that as a location
as opposed to point which is something
which is one of the elements of the data
set
correct yeah so for instance you can ask
the question
given a location what's the expected
number of points
within a certain region yeah i get it
yes okay
so so again i'm coming back to we need
you know
commonality with what we're doing with
time series so are we imagining
a time series so it sounds to me like
select itself
is going to have a hard time working for
time series and this geo case because
it has you know select doesn't know
like if i say select and list there is
no version of select that's
like select indexed for example that
also pays attention to the position in
the list
do you understand what i'm saying we
could imagine a select
index that in addition to having a
criterion applied to the values in the
list
also has something coming into the the
selection function
that knows the position of the elements
in the list yeah
right we don't have that functionality
yeah but the
thing with these composite data
structures
so these data structures like spatial
point data
are very effective in aggregating
potentially very big data
as a as a one thing yeah efficient to
deal with but you're not making you're
not addressing my points here but
go on yes no no but what i'm saying is
that we
we create a this is a very simple query
function that allows you to
filter out yeah that's all good roger
the point that i'm making there is not a
big other
api to these yet okay i understand
i'm saying there are three cases and
they have to be consistent right
there is select which has no way to have
us
to put the position into the criterion
there is time series select
and there is your position point
selection doesn't
position doesn't matter that much for
for for these um
for which for for for um
well i'm sorry what position doesn't
matter much what do you say
the position the posit i mean this the
position in space
matters but the position in a list
doesn't matter no no you're not
getting my point there are three
analogous situations okay
think about the select function right so
gosha had said maybe
we want to extend select to work on time
series right remember you said that
yes a couple of minutes ago right okay
so then the question is
why not extend select to work on spatial
point data as well
okay answer because we need to know
not only the values of points but also
their
locations right
make sense yes
roger yeah i don't particularly want to
extend select to work on this i mean
i'm trying to explain design consistency
between
three things yeah right which we have to
have to be consistent
right so what i'm saying is
in the case of both time series and
spatial statistics
we believe that the selection criterion
matters it cares where the point is
right which we think doesn't really
matter with select
itself right am i making sense
yes did did you get it roger
no i don't get it okay so let me think
you're confusing
when you say when you say confusing
anything i'm not confusing anything
what i may have confused you however
when when i say
okay let me let me use the term index
and let me use the term location okay
better
okay all right for select
one could imagine including the index
along with
the vowel absolutely but we could right
okay for both spatial point
data and time series you could
it you expect to include the location
you are making the point you don't care
about including the index
and i agree with you on that did you
understand what i'm saying
yes now on the other hand by the time we
are including the location
we could include the index just as we do
in nearest for example
right now i think an analogous design is
what we've done with nearest right
where in the case of nearest let me
remind myself how that works
okay possible forms oh i see that that's
for the
for the output right is not for the
input
right okay
all right so the point that i'm making
is we need consistency of design
between time series select and spatial
point select
and we have to decide we're really going
to have those two different things and i
think the answer is probably yes
right to deal with those two cases do do
we making sense
and the reason that we want those
additional things is because
we want to have a
but you know you know we want to have a
criterion and
a common criterion might be region
within q
for example for the hash point value is
that correct
is that correct am i making sense when
you say
spatial points select right you say i
want to only pick the trees that are
inside the national park
for example which is that right roger
which is member
region within is two regions okay fine
region member queue
okay so so but but am i correct that
that's the code fragment you're
expecting there
yeah okay if is that always the code
fragment
in other words are there other criteria
that you might seriously apply to point
other than region member queue yes
you can use any algebraic notation you
know i understand but like what
you know the part one can be greater
than one point
i'm well aware of that i'm asking
realistically because i'm asking about
this design
because what you're saying in this
design is that you're putting in
you have this thing that i think is a
little bit hicky which is
this thing where you know you're saying
there is an association which gives the
values
and then there is a special key
that you're using to indicate something
which is a value that comes from
somewhere else
right okay so i'm
and i'm also saying that if i look at
spatial point data
where you have a region that defines the
whole region of interest
i'm i'm kind of confu you know i'm kind
of wondering
whether you know whether there is a you
know a cookie cutter
that you might want that basically is a
spatial point select where you just give
it a region
so spatial point data accepts a region
and it does just that
no no so you're saying if you nest
spatial point data's
they will cookie cutter each other is
that correct yeah
if you if you get if you have spatial
point data
no no you understand specifically the
scenario i mentioned that is
you have no we have a thing for that
okay okay so because that came up
because that became another
thing that didn't fit here we had a hash
region
equal to which is not you know
okay this is this is conceptually right
now it's conceptually an analog thing to
select
okay let's just state it up there
paragraph if i have region as another
thing it becomes not conceptually the
same i
so i'm asking my specific question which
is what i would expect is that spatial
point data
of you know val you know what you've got
there is special point data of the point
data
comma a region that if you want to
take you know the um
uh you know if you've got a map of
illinois and you want to just select the
trees in champaign county
that what you would do is to say you've
got spatial point data of all the trees
in illinois
if there are any which there are some at
least um the
uh you know and then then you would
wrap around that spatial point data say
of percent
so to speak comma you know region that
corresponds to champaign county
and that's exactly what we made work
okay fine that's what i would expect to
work and that's what i think should work
and that's all good
okay so let's come back now to this this
selection thing so again the thing that
i'm pushing
is if we do this we have to do it
consistently in time series select
am i making sense i don't know of a
function called time series
i know i'm telling you okay go should
just explained
that there was we wanted to talk about
that so i don't understand but i'm i'm
saying
that we have we're signing up for
something where it has to be consistent
right so we have to think it through so
that we don't make a mistake here
that we can't continue there yeah but
you can
you know time series is the field case
this is not the field case
time series corresponds to random fields
okay
fine fine fine event series
yeah okay event series select
but now what i'm expecting is that it
will actually be the same story
for the event series can be completely
analog to this
event event series can be completely
analog the continuous thing is just not
okay so let's let's look at that for a
second okay so in spatial point select
if we if we have a continuous field here
right not not the stochastic partial
differential equation
just the data right just the data case
and then we want to say select in that
field
right i could could imagine you know
then the point
could be i don't know if the point if
it's more northerly than this
and the tree is this type then do this
and i don't see a reason why the
continuous case wouldn't work exactly
analogously to the discrete case
am i making sense that is in the
continuous case i assume
you have a function that each one of
those
elements of the association is a
function
of position where position by position i
mean location here
when i i don't see how that can work
because
are you selecting the curve let's say
time series or you select there's a
curve coming along with it
okay and you're addressing the points
let's say you pick the points that are
below a certain value
um you're gonna pick a subset a point a
disjoint
you're gonna pick there's gonna be a
disjoint you know
curved pieces that you pick out
you know if you if you're doing that by
value
sure absolutely it's it's like picking
out a strip
in a absolutely it's like a contour map
it's like a contour plot
okay right the contour plot you say i
want
you know this set of things that i'm
going to color blue
in the contour plot that are the things
above
below sea level or something right and
the points are just
you know you have to actually compute
what that
curve or surface in the case of a field
absolutely
and that means that you're probably
going to have to add more points
absolutely just as you do in a contour
plot
yeah so you're probably gonna have to
add the edge points
yeah so it's like list contour plot so
that's not
at all like this case at all it's
nothing like this case
let's understand that for a minute okay
this case that you're describing here
right that has no additional points
being filled in is just like a syntactic
select exactly yeah it's
actually the analog of select the other
thing isn't the [ __ ] select
okay all right let's insist on that
consistency
let's understand let's go back and
understand that
right because in the case of a
continuous thing
you are going to want to select
okay so here's a question
okay so what i want to do is i want to
draw a picture
where i want to color red every place
where the
you know level of where the density of
lizards is greater than such and such
right and i measured certain
lizard density in certain places and i
imagine there's a lizard density field
right so of our various functions what
is it that allows me to color red
the there are more lizards in this area
um
you know in this area they're more than
you know 10 lizards per square meter or
something
so then you derive a field okay so
that's what's called the intensity here
um you can either do it directly in your
you know in the
in the graphics in the plot functions
because we have
capabilities of doing that or
you get the function which is called
intensity or the point intensity and
then you that's a derived field
and now you're you're back to you know
doing whatever you want with a function
that you want to
uh color a certain level yeah but maybe
but you've got to feed it back into
whatever the
base coordinate system is
that is if it's geo coordinates whatever
okay i understand
actually there's an interesting comment
on our live stream here um
which is talking about part syntax
and the somewhat exotic idea
that what would happen if
i don't know whether we could do this
but what would happen if we extended
part
syntax to allow keys
that could sample things in things like
time series so for example normally
in a time series we would say you know
or event series whatever
it doesn't matter because it's the same
in both cases here
okay so we would say something like um
we have a series
and we would say element six for example
okay
now a question would be i this is
probably crazy
a question is clearly we have things
like spans right now here
the question is this is probably crazy
right it's probably crazy
never mind you know
something like this um
i don't know this makes any sense i mean
the issue is you're trying to
in a time series you're trying to get at
something which is not
you know we need a consistent way to get
at
essentially this this base quantity
which in the case of an ordinary list is
index
in the case of something like time
series is the time
we need a consistent way to do that in
functions whose primary
objective is to do things based on
values
that make sense and it would be nice to
have
a way to handle that that would work
i'm thinking about this in
you know in other words imagine that
there was a symbolic thing
that let's imagine not a very good name
but let's imagine something like base
value
let's imagine that symbolic construct
and that that symbolic construct could
occur
in no that's not a good good name but
but you know
that even in select you've got some list
okay that
somehow the the um you know that you
could do something like this
right this is a bad you know this
particular syntax is no good but but
um but you me in this mean you mean the
analog of position in this
particular case right that's index in
this particular case
yes yeah right but i mean so what i'm
saying is
a a standardized way to get at
i mean this is this is the analog of
something i mean this would be an
interesting way to do this because you
know right now
and for the last 30 years we've had you
know the map index
mechanism where we say you know
um well we have something like this
where
i mean this is a more general discussion
but where we have something like this
right right now what if instead of that
we could simply say
map f hash comma
base value
and if that basically knows
right if it's a symbolic representation
of its environment
right see what i'm saying right
i think i think we need to have this
discussion
differently yeah different group this is
an ild lcc
type discussion but i think it informs a
little bit what we're talking about so
can somebody who's who's pming here
japan i have a note to add it to an il
team
okay
um all right so
that leaves this a little bit up in the
air this hash point thing
it's some i i get what you're suggesting
it seems
okay i think there might be a better
general mechanism
um okay so let's look here
so this newly added
yeah it's not fully added yet um
in the sense that it requires this new
object to represent them so it can't be
sort of live
obviously no i understand so but this is
this is something where you've got
archaeological sites or something here
cool
okay okay
so then this
is going to bring back this is nice
um okay so this is then
a um uh four spatial point data there's
a certain
the summary thing is a
sample here yeah this is obviously not
consistent right
set count is a is a yeah we've changed
this is this
so this is going to get updated okay so
it should just be the
the usual thing that we do for these
it's just lowercase explanatory
output type stuff i think
maybe maybe not maybe i'm wrong about
that i think what we'd normally say is
data set
or something there and that would be
some kind of thing represented as a data
set
and summary would be something that's
more human readable
yeah we haven't seriously looked at this
particular
aspect here the the big thing was to get
sort of en enough interesting kind of
data sets because a lot
of them are yeah it's great you know
okay so lots of good data sets of point
data
all right so now we've got these other
functions here and i'm not gonna have a
chance to go through everything as you
predicted roger here
oops this is a this is a meaty topic i
mean okay i understand i know you've
been working on this for what three
years or something
yeah it's been on and off but you know
and and
but but as i said it's a hard topic and
it's a slightly meaty topic
okay all right so i but but okay i can't
find this
this mean intensity thing is that
something i should be able to find
it says not found okay my
my bad intensity now
okay thank you
but i'm not sure if we have a
okay okay
this is the simplest model you know so
with a constant
okay so this is mean point intensity
means
number of points per unit area is that
correct that's correct
so if i do this on geo positions do i
get units
it's a good question do you get units
yeah you should because if
you compute the go area it returns you
units then you should get the units
okay so here if i take this and i say
for example let's take this
and let's say um let's do this let's say
capital cities in europe
okay hopefully okay there we go
all right great and now we say
um now can i directly feed these to
special point data
we should make sure that works right
you get what i'm saying in what in other
respects if you
i so gauche i i should have brought this
up
but maybe i did but the thing is if that
prop
for that entity has a um
position property it has a geoposition
property we can extract
it and treat them as points okay so we
do that in a bunch of other i think we
talked about this but i
didn't go back okay so if you didn't do
it you should do it
okay so right now that will give geo
positions okay so now i can say spatial
point data of that
right but you really want
you can do that but now you sort of now
it's going to approximate the
observation region
with the convex hole of those points
okay
and that's not probably what you want
well okay
so if i now say mean point intensity
okay okay all right
and it did miles because why
why did it pick miles that's probably
because that's
we are in united states okay all right
okay
so it's a default is the same convention
as geo
area or so what you're saying all right
okay fine
fine fine fine so now if i were to say
for example geo area of your spatial
point data would that give me the
bounding box
bounding region area no
but maybe it should probably should
right so it's not going to work on a
special data as a whole but
you can access the uh the region measure
as a property on the special point data
okay so okay okay so notice the point
that
that in spatial point data here given
that
this is uh you know it's not completely
obvious to me what the summary blob
should look like in this particular case
right given that we know these are that
long i mean and it should probably say
here that it's geo points
right yes it probably should instead of
dimension two why doesn't it just say
you know something about geodata or
something
does that make sense and then we can
then we could
mimic this here yeah i don't think we
should be
i think it should be more specific right
by the time it knows it's geo
data makes sense
okay so now if i say
let's see smooth point intensity so wait
a minute if i say
if i use one of these estimators is that
going to have another argument is that
like a pdf or something
uh point intensity function right
yeah they think how do i point you know
spatial point data
okay how do i get something where i can
show the smoothed histogram
i mean i guess if i just say here geo
smooth histogram
yeah that would of of percent two then
what i should get
is interesting okay that's where they're
the most countries i guess
um the smaller countries yes
right um
okay okay but so now explain to me what
so let's let's look just for fun if i
say
geographics can i do this
how would i combine the geopoint
that i get from the mean um from oh i
see
no i see there's a different thing which
is where is the mean
mean point intensity right i get it okay
so explain what is point intensity now
so we've extended all of these uh
histogram and so on functions to be able
to show intensities so they can
use the same units
by the way by the way is this the
randomness test
we don't call it randomness test for
hypothesis for generic hypotheses do we
we call them test yeah they all called
test
i see but but by saying randomness test
i mean we don't have a randomness test
as a built-in thing but this is a
spatial randomness
i okay so i'm supposed to read it as
spatial randomness in
test yes that's what it's called i mean
we could call it something else no no
no no okay fine fine
okay and it's kind of a stupid thing
because
what that means um
is basically uniform is what i
understand like meteorites we could test
whether the meteorite distribution on
the earth
is uniform or not yeah that's what this
test this is what spatial randomness
means in the geocache it's per unit area
is that correct
yeah okay so so what do some of these
other things do here
okay so that homogeneity measures
that's that's kind of a meaty part and
that's
um that's sort of second order
statistics
okay so the intensity things are first
order statistics
if i take this thing and i say of my
data set here
wherever it was of percent four and i
say
ripley k
percent four
the heck is that now now you can plot
that's a
univariate function
that you can plot so so how would i do
that i would say
plot this of r
r goes from now what do i do here
what do i do here yeah zero to
max ranges okay what is max radius how
do i get that out of this thing
kosher eduardo is it max radius
well i don't know you wrote it i didn't
okay so that didn't work so how do we do
this
do you understand the question yes yes
yes yes
um so the workflow there is not the
cleanest
go to the replicate page and we'll see i
mean we can always type in that number
because it comes in with a username no
no i understand it right
i get it i get it but i mean so plot
doesn't
right now support having units in the
range is that correct
i'm surprised by that actually i'm
really surprised by that
although maybe what what went wrong is
that the zero doesn't have units
and the upper limit does
okay dandy but i want to see a geo
example
look at this that was the problem right
yeah
yeah this is kind of a piece of hackery
here
um all right so we need to deal with
that in some way
um
okay
uh all right i think we
are not going to be able to well
obviously we're not finishing this today
now this stuff here this exists or this
is coming in the future
no it exists okay
cool okay so each one of these then so i
can say random variate
of hardcore point process is that
correct we actually said random point
configuration because one
if you one instance is basically a
collection of points
then if you can have many collections of
points
which i'm saying it's a different okay i
get it
okay but now how does that relate to if
i have a random walk
process and i say random i say
for that i say random what do i say
random variant what is the analog random
function oh right okay so this is so
random point process is the analog of
random function
is that correct not a random random
point configuration
is the random i'm sorry i'm sorry that's
what i meant to say yeah right that's we
didn't want to call it random point
patterns
oh god no yeah right
there's some wording here that we're
going to have to work on but
okay so then um
there's a whole guide page for these
guys and easy to click around
okay um
okay so let's take a random thing here
koshy
okay
so this is essentially a cauchy
distribution of what
so so you have a base
set of clusters which are poisson
meaning uniform
and then around each one of those you
use a cauchy
distribution for the radial it's it's um
for the radial component of
how they spread can i can i have any
distribution there
can i just put in a pdf of anything yes
which one is that name and scott right
layman's code point process you can put
distribution in i see cool
okay all right so this one the the
caution because it's a heavy tail
so that's something where you know often
seedlings fall close to the tree
but some seedlings are very light so the
wind can catch them and they fly
far away on occasion okay okay like
children of various
yeah anyway never mind apple falled
close to tree or not or
or the apple sprouts wings and goes far
away
yes so this is modeling that kind of
phenomena
okay okay um
uh fair enough but okay but so so then
um
let me see so is it possible to get
analytical results here
of if i say just if i define a koshi
point process
here but super rarely stephen this is
part of what makes it hard
none of our symbolics none of our
numerics hold up
it's all it's mostly sort of simulation
based computation
a lot of time so is the is that this
mcmc type stuff and so on
yes or what all the way okay so
we have somebody working on getting at
least a wfr version of mcmc up and
running
um okay that's interesting that that's
what needs to happen there
um uh
i mean not all the simulations are that
way but but but it's true for
an awful lot of other computations too
we just cannot you know we're sort of
out of
a very high dimensional yeah i get it
you know right because it's high
dimensional because you can move every
point around in the thing
yeah and that that represents a part of
the configuration space
yep the okay
interesting so okay so does this stuff
work in any other dimensions
for the points yeah i think so right in
any dimension
so for geo if i have flying objects like
satellites and things
if i were to do this for the geo
positions of satellites which have a
third
which have a height coordinate in them
it would just work is that correct
now so gao works the the the regular geo
positions that we have
uh but the regular geo positions do
contain uh
heights yeah but we don't deal with it
none of the models first of all generate
geo
all of these none of these generate geo
things are all non-geo at this time
yes so if i wanted to actually model
seedlings and trees
i'm sort of out of luck i mean except in
so far as i have a coordinate patch
that is you know my forest is in uh
something
you can simulate so you can simulate geo
uh yeah all of this simulation i mean in
the estimation works as well in geo
it's just that for geoposition where
we've we're limiting ourselves to the
surface of the earth partly because
otherwise it's very hard to
to think what's what's the g or this
what's the distance function
it's point it's it's literally distance
it's it's
um you know euclidean distance right i
mean unless i'm mistaken
what you would do is the um jose maybe
you can speak to this i mean look this
is a corner case right now
but what you're saying is go ahead we
don't have a notion of geo distance in
3d because it would depend on the path
you are using for example
do you allow yourself to go through the
earth or not
i see i see
okay so but given two satellites
we can take their geo positions and we
can make a
geo position xyz or something from
those is that true right so if you go
through geoposition xyz
then you are purely in 3d and then you
could just use a gradient distance
okay so so in the case of so we do a lot
of computations
actually we take it whatever you know
geoposition we map it to xyz
and we do the computation there so if i
say geoposition
of um let's say iss is that going to be
the international space station
oh come on this is uh
i think we're looking at a version
that's broken here
um that's surprising uh
oh work this time okay so if we say this
i would assume that it will give us the
current location of the international
space station
although this prototype build might not
do that successfully
okay there we go so that's now x1 that's
that long elevation time
right so now presumably i can say geo
what is it called the xyz thing
geography
what's that xyz okay
so geo position xyz of this
is now location relative to the center
of the earth is that correct
yes
what are those coordinates what is that
so it's x y c with respect to the green
age frame say
i see i see okay
okay so given this that in principle
is point process i mean point
configurationable so to speak so the
satellites in orbit
in principle could be turned into
something so presumably you take
geoposition xyz
in uh uh spatial
point data right presumably if i said
you know let's make a table of of these
three of those and now i say spatial
point data
of that splatteroo
how come
guys unexpected
sorry okay i mean so
but in principle this should work is
that a true statement yes
in principle yes i don't know what to do
with this to be honest but but
but the problem is that the way that we
look at the geo
data it's is is working on the surface
of the earth is
where it said and so right now when you
give the satellite position which is you
know
somewhere above the the surface of the
space
you know we we don't you know like
we don't really know how this kind of
applies i get it i get it i get it i get
it
so let's just i mean it's a corner case
right so i'm not
going to make a big production out of it
although generating errors is clearly
not what we should be doing here but
but um uh i mean it seems to me the
obvious thing to do
is to if you were given 3d coordinates
i would think
hmm
[Music]
well it's not clear what you should do i
mean let's imagine it's it's
pine trees on a mountain right
and somebody on from their gps they read
out
the elevation as well as the geo
positions
and they entered those in the
geoposition thing
you you know as you say it's not obvious
what you want to do
well we we right now if if you if you do
that with the height we basically forget
about the height
and we try to with x y g o position x y
z
but i think in the case of g o position
x y z
it's much more likely that you are
really talking about x y z coordinates
and to
to be i mean it could you know given
that it says xyz in its name
so to speak um i mean no that that's
that was an incorrect emphasis because
just it's just a location
right i mean my suggestion would be that
what we do
is we by default we ignore
height in ordinary geo position if you
want height
convert to geo position xyz and then you
simply take that to the euclidean
position
does that make sense yeah and then
there's the 3d euclidean position if
that's what you gave here
now somewhat awkwardly there's also time
coordinates here but i think you should
just ignore those
that's why you have the word spatial in
the name yes
the okay and so presumably
right okay cool so okay but if i want to
make a koshy point process
in france for example if i want
that process but constrained to france
how would i do that
you can you mean simulate points
yeah i want to just like we say random i
mean right now
we have the very nice you know i think
we have random point
of don't we don't we allow one to just
say france here
we do and then say you know 200 points
here
and then we can literally just generate
parameter freeway so no but i think that
we
the we didn't initially we didn't
support geo regions okay
okay and so but i think that we should
have remembered
to add geo regions when we did all the
geo integration with geometry
yeah i think that looks like a bug to me
um i mean yeah yeah okay but this will
work
right if i do that then i can just say
geo list plot and i'm off and running
and this particular thing if i do this
what the heck oh you've got a debugging
thing in there
this is a okay that worked okay so now
for example
you should check into this debugging
whatever that is right
yes can somebody make a note please yes
do so right now
okay all right okay so then here in
percent 14
that's what i should be obviously yeah
yeah it's probably it's probably
debugging from visualization this is a
prototype build
so here what i would be able to do for
this
i could say for example um
pair correlation function
of percent 14 and that will now give me
a function
and now i could say the value of that at
10 miles am i right
it's a little odd why is it zero
there might be no points in that scale
distances okay so let's let's try
uh how big is france let's say 300 miles
that's enough
weird why is that is that because it's
too big
probably yeah okay so that's the
pair correlation that's the number of
pairs of points
that are within distance within 30 miles
of each other
and that tells us the effective density
given that you're at one of those points
what is the density of other points
per unit area right that's the units of
this
um
okay okay
all right but so so there's a little bit
of of of dealing with the fact that
you've got these
i mean i would argue that there's
probably some
uh accessor for point statistic function
that removes units am i making sense
so that you don't have this weird stuff
that basically just commits to a certain
set of units and lets you just do
numerical computations in them right so
that i'm not giving 30 miles here
so i'm giving so i'm returning a
function that is
that takes unitless inputs does that
make sense uh
we should to do that we'd have to think
about exactly
what which unit or maybe specified by
the uh
yeah right right exactly um right
because then
then you can merrily go along and use
plot and everything else that doesn't
expect units
in in dealing with these functions right
and it's also good for inter conversion
with standard statistics and other
things
where you know eventually everything
will take units but it's not clear that
you even want the units
in um for some of the stuff
all right well cruel this is really nice
stuff
get another meeting scheduled it's going
to take i reckon it's going to take at
least two more
roger do you have an estimate okay no i
didn't think that's roughly where i'm at
too
it's just it is a lot of stuff the good
news is that you have a background
you know with statistical physics and
other things so you're probably familiar
with
with some of it some of it i mean except
i've never seen i mean
you know two-point correlation function
i understand that
okay i mean it raises questions about
endpoint
correlation functions yeah look this is
this is it it won't be hard just working
your way through it it it will be very
clear
right i mean i think that the things
that um
uh you know just just for comparison
there's a there's an
r package that they developed for 20
years that has 2000 functions that does
this
and i think we cover pretty well
in 40 to 50 functions
good there
i think um
okay so i mean just to understand just
to poke at a couple of things and then i
will disappear here like geo region
value plot
yes and
um does it play nice with this
i'm not thinking it through correctly
but i mean yeah things like geohistogram
and so on do they play nice with all of
this
if i were to take la hill let me let me
take yes yes and if they don't it's it's
planned okay
they don't because they're disabled for
the time being
for the prototype build but it was just
a branch problem right
okay okay but the the support is there
for you know to do the natural things
for these visualization functions okay
so for example geo smooth histogram
applied to the
spatial point data obtained from this
will give the same results here is that
correct
yes yes except that i could
now if i if i put the cookie cutter in
so to speak and i
and i put a region specification in the
spatial point data
then my geo histogram will presumably go
to zero
outside of that region is that correct
yes
is that is that is that um and what does
the geo smooth histogram do
does it also chop to zero outside of the
specified region of special point data
well no because then well so that's
that's not what's happening in the in
the in this moving
you may get out of the boundary yes
functions
that's that's how those kernel functions
kernel estimators work
you know i see that they have a kernel
and the column is yeah if
that's what it does yeah if you wanna if
you wanna have a sharp edges then you're
gonna
you're probably better with the you know
beaning also like the histogram point
intensity
okay okay
both of those our people on the live
stream
seem enthusiastic about um um
uh this functionality
saying is it coming in 12 2 yes it is
that's the point here
that's why we're rushing to do these
reviews
um uh
mikhail says could be useful for some
special clustering applications such as
industrial inspection systems
interesting um that is interesting
that's one that i haven't heard of
before people use it to track
like animals animal herds like birds
nests or animals
yeah right
um okay ali is saying the two things we
really need
are spatial statistics and differential
geometry
yeah those are good areas um
okay then ethan is commenting
how does this fit with machine learning
can one use spatial machine learning to
uh on this stuff in other words if you
have a spatial point data
object and you feed it to
let's say classify what does it do
i think nothing at this point but it
could
i mean there's a just the obvious bridge
of making sure that it understands we
can make that sure happen for 12
2 that it correctly understands what
spatial point data is
and does what it does for point
collections then
expanding out and doing something more
clever
in machine learning for that case will
take a little bit more time
right i don't know whether we have an
encoder for geo positions in
in machine learning do we i mean that
knows i don't even know i i suspect you
basically have to flatten the earth
i i'll be surprised if i'll be very very
surprised if there's a neuron that way
of encoding you know the the uh
topology of the earth basically
let me know then yes i don't know either
but actually it's an interesting
question i don't even know for
for cyclic variables i've never heard of
those in machine learning
that is you know you you normally have
um you know the concept i suppose
yeah i've never heard of that i don't
know how that works
it's a good question for the machine
learning team
um a lot of applications doesn't deal
with the whole earth
i know a lot of applications deals with
something local like a field
like the bird's nest you know forest
right um
let's see this is uh
and in fact we project and if we have to
deal with the whole earth there's like a
singularity at some point
fine so you can't you can't do that yet
so i see so so your point here is
if if i were to do just just for the
hell of it i mean i could you're saying
that if i do let me just try one thing
and then we'll we'll um
earth oceans so that
okay
okay great now let's say geo position
i assume it will give us centers of
those
okay great okay so now if i said your
list plot
of this oh we're gonna say
crazy bug okay all right so now how do i
see
what happens in this case
um so you're talking about singularity
i'm i'm just
well i'm saying that that eventually
we're projecting our observation region
on a plane and the more you get to the
answer well i understand that i'm asking
what does this
how do i see that there is a problem
here that is
it's very hard actually to see like
you'd have to have many many many many
points uh no but i'm but i'm asking this
question i'm asking
if i look at the two-point correlation
function here right
am i going to see is the pacific ocean
going to wrap around
with a like if i say what's the
expected number of points within radius
r is it going to know that the engine
is yes oh yes yeah
um okay good i mean this led to
i mean jose has been super helpful jose
has developed a lot of things here to
make
geocomputation as opposed to geographics
work and that's also led to the
unification of geometry and geography
and it also led to the visualizations
that you saw the spatial
right visualizations of density and
intensity
along the route of doing this project so
it drove many things along the way
right uh
uh rich comments that one could use sine
as an activation function
to do the circular thing not
not completely getting that but that's
interesting um
yes uh
bob is saying no need to flatten for
neuron that's just his 3d position it's
not obvious to me that's a good idea
i mean it's uh whether that's the
correct set of features
um uh ali is asking what the center of
oceans means we have a very definite
notion of center right right now
for what what is how does that work uh
jose the
the thing that gives you the the center
of a region so if i say region
of can i do this region of pacific ocean
well the centers that we assigned there
are
manually chosen so for every geo
entity we have a position why didn't
this work
sorry why didn't this thing work
the
i think what what is preparedness do you
discretize it
so what do i say here i say discretize
region
discretize region and perhaps you need
polygon i
i don't remember nice
okay and then i have to say polygon here
right you have to extract the body
though that workflow that i just gave
probably should work okay so there's
there's the pacific ocean like that
triangulated and so now we can obviously
find the center of that
right confine that centroid for that
right but
the point of that won't be on the
surface
exactly right so then you have to
project it to the surface if you want to
know the surface position there
if that's what you think you mean by the
center
yeah that's what you're thinking about
but what i meant is that the center
the position we assigned to that is is
just
some sometimes
right bob is asking about clustering
statistics
analyzing clusters
3d vector so it's asking whether you can
use the spatial statistics stuff to
analyze
clusters i would think the answer is yes
isn't that part of the point i mean if
you have 3d
points you can just use this
all right anyway cool functionality look
forward to further review
and um we should wrap up for now
so thanks guys thanks to folks on the
live stream
uh see y'all soon